and suddenly boom I got a face full of
gas and then the pilot light jumped and
my face caught on fire Jay Leno opens up
in his first sit-down TV interview since
suffering third degree burns on his face
and body and reveals he went home to his
wife before going to the hospital it
just seemed like the right thing to do
and it and I think it was on Wednesday
Jay sat down with hodakotb on The Today
Show and explained that the accident
occurred while he was working on one of
his cars with a friend Dave kolacki last
month it was a 1907 White Steam car so
the fuel line was clogged so I was
underneath it trying to clog and I said
blow some air through the line the super
clip and then a lot of them and suddenly
boom I got a face full of gas and then
the pilot like jumped and my face caught
on fire and I said to my friend I said
Dave I'm on fire and they're like okay I
said no Dave I'm on fire thankfully Dave
was there to smother the fire and call
9-1-1 it was horrific it was a scary
thing of course it's no secret that Jay
is an avid car lover in fact he's dished
to E.T about his passion in the past I
grew up in a rural area in New England
where there was always a broken car in a
field you know so that's kind of where
it started plus I'm one of those people
that think you know the heart works best
when the head and the hands work
together makes you appreciate how easy
is to make money work with your head and
while Jay loves his cars when the
incident occurred it was his wife Mabus
who was top of mind I drove home right
after that my wife doesn't drive anymore
and I didn't want her stuck and not
knowing what was going on
it it just seemed like the right thing
to do and it and I think it was so you
loved your wife more than you worried
about yourself yeah that's it yeah was
that it well I think there's something
for that the two have been married more
than four decades I flew to Los Angeles
I had about 500 and a guy had a 55 Buick
for 350. I dated my wife in that car we
met in that car let's try something
about it what did your wife say when she
saw you oh thrilled yeah yeah Jay
suffered severe burns on his face chest
and hands and spent more than a week at
a burn center he's doing very well he's
got a very strong attitude I've had to
tell him that for the time being he
needs to sit back and take care of Jay
doctors had to scrape away layers of
burnt skin a painful procedure we have
to remove the unhealthy tissue and you
remove the unhealthy tissue through a
number of different ways a process known
as debridement sometimes that's
scrubbing it down and sometimes it's
shaving it down but Jay recently joked
to the Wall Street Journal that he has a
brand new face and added that it's
better than what was there before and a
few days after his release from the
hospital Jay returned to the stage
performing for a sold-out crowd at the
comedy magic club in Hermosa Beach
California where an eyewitness told E.T
the comedian appeared to be in good
spirits Arsenio Hall opened for Jay and
praised his friend after the show
calling him an amazing guy as for Jay he
says he doesn't want anyone feeling bad
for him people work with their hands get
injured every single day yeah and I
don't want to be some whiny celebrity
who is me don't want to be one of these
people
foreign